for the next step let's do an exercise
that focuses on extracting out the value
of one of those attributes we're going
to do this exercise a little bit
differently you'll implement this on the
Udacity platform and we'll be able to
verify that your code is correct after
this video you'll see an IDE like this
where it contains some starter code as
well as some J unit tests in a separate
tab in particular we want you to
implement this function to get the max
temperature for a day you're given a
weather JSON string formatted the same
way as you would get from the open
weather map service and you also get the
day index that we care about feel free
to play around with the code in Android
studio or a separate development
environment before you paste your answer
here or you can use the Udacity IDE
whichever feels more natural to you